welcome back well now try to see what
trigonometric identity we can come up
with if we if we start off with cosine
cosine of alpha plus beta cosine of
alpha let's play let's see if we can
rewrite this as another combination of
cosines and sines and alpha and beta so
let's let's get started and if you've
already watched the the sine equivalent
of this this proof will be pretty
similar and then how we operate and we
get a kind of similar answering
something interesting is just to kind of
compare the difference between sine of
alpha plus beta and cosine of alpha plus
beta after we're done so just like that
last proof let's say that this angle and
that color isn't bright enough let's see
this to yellow let's say that this angle
right here is alpha and this angle right
here is beta right so alpha we wanted a
cosine of alpha plus beta so alpha plus
beta is this large angle right here all
right so what's the cosine of that
sohcahtoa so cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse write sohcahtoa cus 8c so Chi
Toa so cosine so cosine is equal to
adjacent over hypotenuse so for this
large angle what's the adjacent it's
line AC so that equals blind AC that's
the adjacent line AC the length of line
AC over the length of line what's the
hypotenuse a B right all right ac over a
B now let's see what we can do with this
a AC adjacent over hypotenuse now can we
write AC in any other interesting way
and combination of some of the other
lines on this
this very fortunately designed graph
let's see well is it a see the same
thing as AF this big line AF - what is
this this is a D right okay that's a
deed looks almost like a moment rewrite
that as a D D as in as in dog
there you go so AF - de right because
it's oh I forgot to draw some things we
assume that this line is perpendicular
to that line we assumed this line is
perpendicular to that line we assume
that line is perpendicular to that line
right and then by definition that is
because we drew it that way but anyway
so now you know that this line is
parallel to this line so we can definite
and this line is perpendicular so we
know that AF this long line minus de is
equal to AC does that make sense AF this
big one whoops this big line AF - the
shorter line is the same thing as AC
right so let me write that down that
equals AF - de - de all of that over a B
all of that over a B and then of course
we can rewrite that as and I'm going to
switch to some some different colors I
can rewrite that is a F over a B right
and we switch to maybe green minus D e
over a B so we have now a F over a B -
de over a B and those are kind of
nonsensical ratios to me wouldn't it be
great if we could say express it somehow
is AF AF / AE because then we could you
know say well that's that's cosine of
alpha and then do something from there
well well let's try so let's let's try
to rewrite this first expression
so I'll switch back to the purple just
so you know where this first expression
is coming from let's say let's see if we
can break this down as AF / AE times
something else well we could just
algebraically do it that's equivalent to
AF / I might run out of space / AE / AE
x AE / a B you're saying Sal where did
you get that from well you can kind of
say my motivation was to have AF s ratio
of over AE and I just you know I just
set it up so that the multiplication
would cancel out because the ADEs was
canceled out and you'd be left with AF
over a B right so this this is a
reasonable thing to do I I hope you see
so and then let me switch to the green
and do something similar de over a B de
over a B doesn't make much sense but if
I could maybe do de over B E then I
might be you know if this angle I can
see is you know it's similar to alpha or
beta then maybe I can I can make some
progress so let's say de d e / b e x and
what are the same thing you know you
just have to multiply B times B E over a
B and just like in that that sign proof
and we'll do the same thing here so
let's see figure out what this angle up
here is right because if we know that
and then these ratios become useful so
this angle is alpha then we know that
this angle right here is alpha right
because de because this line is parallel
to AF and you learn that in geometry and
if this angle is alpha we know that this
angle right here is 90 minus alpha
because it's complementary right because
this whole angle is 90 degrees so this
is 90 minus alpha and since this angle
90 minus alpha this angle 90 and this
angle add up to 180 we could figure out
that this is alpha and if you don't
believe me add up alpha plus 90 plus 90
minus alpha and you will get 180 degrees
so this angle up here angle DBE is alpha
so that's very interesting
so can we rewrite these these ratios as
as the sines or cosines of alpha or beta
so let's try let me switch back to
purple so that equals what is AF / ayee
AF / ayee well if we look at this right
triangle that's the adjacent over the
hypotenuse for alpha right adjacent over
hypotenuse that's cosine so it's cosine
of alpha cosine of alpha and what's a e
over a B AE over a B well they're
similar it's if we look at this big
right triangle right here that is the
adjacent over the hypotenuse for beta so
that's cosine of beta cosine of beta
switch my colors - de over B e de over B
e well this is alpha right then a little
smudge you probably can't read it but
that was alpha we showed that that was
alpha so de is the opposite and B E is
the hypotenuse so opposite over
hypotenuse is sine right so that's sine
of alpha sine of alpha and what is B e
over a b b:e over a B look at this
triangle again well for beta that is B e
is the opposite and ABC potenuse so
opposite over hypotenuse for beta so
it's the sine of beta times a sine of
beta I'm running eyespace up to another
line sine of beta
pretty neat so we have now learned I'll
rewrite everything in a in a new end and
an exciting color
the color selection is different Oh oh
boy what am i doing okay let me do it in
light blue so we now know that the
cosine of alpha plus beta is equal to
the cosine of both of them multiplied so
cosine of alpha cosine theta
Mobb cosine of beta minus the sine of
both of them multiplied minus sine of
alpha times sine of beta I hope you
found that as satisfying as I do see you
next presentation